[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de dimanche en politique où nous
parlons aujourd'hui argent les feuilles
d'imposition sont arrivés dans nos
boîtes aux lettres est la mauvaise
surprise pour certains
emmanuel macron avait promis une baisse
de la taxe d'habitation mais pour
certains contribuables
elle augmente pourquoi le président de
la république at il trahi sa promesse
trois invités sur ce plateau pour
débattre jean claude grenier c'est de
président de la communauté de communes
qui s'intitule loup lisons face à lui
christophe lejeune député la république
en marche de haute saône et puis jean
baptiste ganne you mr les républicains
eux de dole n'oubliez pas vous pouvez
commenter l'émission grâce à twitter et
au hashtag dit mme paul fc comme
dimension politique franche comté alors
première question et je m'adresse à jean
claude grenier avant d'être maire est ce
que vous pensiez que la fiscalité locale
c'est aussi compliqué que ça non l'aveu
à la bruère de comme tout citoyen se
feuille d'impôts quand on arrive en bas
à droite qu'est ce qu'on a payé on
compare avec l'année d'avant il augmente
et où saab et c'est tout simplement
souhaité bozic
monsieur gagnon jean baptiste gagne ou
avant d'arriver aux affaires
vous pensiez que c'était aussi compliqué
que ça disons que le mécanisme qui
arrive ajustements à la somme finale est
difficilement compréhensible pour tous
les citoyens et pour les élus c'est vrai
qu'il faut un apprentissage avant de
comprendre comme comment tout ça
fonctionne c'est certain et vous
monsieur les jeunes vous avez été maire
de boudou cours 580 habitants se sentent
lui voilà vous pensiez que c'est aussi
compliqué que ça effectivement c'est une
grande autonomie qui a été donnée aux
collectivités locales de lever l'impôt
local et forcément ça demande une
certaine pédagogie aussi bien pour les
lui lorsqu'il découvre que pour ceux
qu'on les concitoyens que lorsqu'elle
voit arriver la feuille d'imposition
évidemment on va pas tout expliquer dans
le détail mais on va essayer d'être le
plus clair possible mais on commence par
la mauvaise idée de la semaine est la
mauvaise idée
de gérald darmanin le ministre de
l'action et des comptes publics
il a communiqué le nom des 55 villes et
donc des mères de plus de 100000
habitants qui avaient augmenté leur taxe
d'habitation
c'est devenu sur les réseaux sociaux
balances ton maire hashtag balances ton
air un peu comme balances ton port
contre les violences sexuelles face aux
femmes alors des militants lrm de chez
vous et puis certains contribuables et
internautes s'en sont donné à coeur joie
vous jean baptiste se gagne au gagnant
vous n'êtes pas dans l'eau quand vous
avez vu ça vous avez fait ouf je le
savais puisque évidemment les taux
d'imposition qui ont été votées par la
ville de dole
on sait que n'ont pas bougé sur la taxe
d'habitation et on a baissé sur la taxe
foncière parce que l'agglomération
augmenté simplement sur cette actualité
de la semaine et l'initiative de gérald
à marlin les ide admissibles et les
inadmissible parce que ça m'étonne
beaucoup d'ailleurs de lui parce qu'il a
été maire donc il sait ce que c'est et
unité dans une partie que vous bien sûr
au delà des partis politiques des uns et
des autres je crois que c'est un esprit
et
cette comparaison avec balances ton port
balances ton mère était absolument mal
venu et je crois qu'en fait ça cache un
déficit de communication en amont sur le
sujet monsieur grenier vous avez vu ça
vous avez réagi comment on va se la
colère au départ on comprend pas c'est
une insulte
les mecs sont insultés c'est un dédit
commence une remise en cause de
l'autonomie des collectivités locales
alors on se dit à un moment donné ils
n'ont pas tout compris je pense qu'ils
avaient bien compris il ya une vraie
campagne de dénigrement pour les élus
locaux
même si le président essayait de se
rattraper aujourd'hui il ya vraiment des
années servit colère des élus locaux qui
se sentent insultés
au fond d'eux mêmes parce qu'en fait ça
y'a aucune aucune raison pour que les
gens balancent leur mère et s'ils
doivent les balances et il a des
élections pour ça ils seront bien le
faire au gouvernement de le dire
christophe lejeune vous vous êtes donc
la république en marche député de la
haute saône c'est principalement des
militants de votre corps qui ont fait ça
vous avez réagi comment quand vous avez
vu ça écoutez il ya deux choses moi je
suis profondément triste pour les trente
maires et présidents de 30000 maires et
présidents de communautés de communes
qui n'ont pas augmenté les impôts et on
oublie d'en parler ah si on parle des
6000 et pas des 30000 je crois qu'il
faut aussi leur rendre hommage et la
deuxième deuxième chose je me range
totalement dans les propos de jacqueline
gourault mardi après midi lors des
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
la minute la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires
qui a dit que c'était inadmissible voilà
moi je aller je pense que c'est un gros
loupé alors on va donc par les impôts
locaux aujourd'hui les uns pour le coz
donc sont payés par les locataires et
des propriétaires
la taxe d'habitation est payée par tous
sauf ceux qui en sont dispensés comme
dirait la pallice car ils ont de faibles
revenus par les impôts fonciers sont
payés uniquement par les propriétaires
alors si tu l'as cette année la
situation est la suivante
christophe lejeune faisait référence
6000 communes en france ont augmenté
leur taxe d'habitation 6000 sur les 35
milles et kehl et puis quand on regarde
notre région
la bourgogne franche comté c'est stable
dans deux mille neuf cent trente
communes dont dole par exemple en hausse
7 110 communes seulement et puis on
baisse il y en a quand même 97 communes
mais en franche comté on bat un record
direction maintenant grand-charmont pour
entrer dans le vif du sujet grand
charmont dans cette es gorille celle des
villes entre 5000 et 10000 habitants
détient la première place elle bat un
record
la plus forte augmentation de la taxe
d'habitation + 30 % réaction et
explications sur place dans cette cité
dortoir aux portes de montbéliard on se
serait bien passé de cette première
place dans le classement des hausses
inattendues de la taxe d'habitation + 32
% une hausse mal perçu même si tous les
avis ne sont pas encore tombés dans les
boîtes gouvernement trouve tout le monde
dans un petit village comme ça où c'est
vraiment ouvriers 30% fin nos salaires
augmentent pas à juste titre le pouvoir
d'achat dont plus voilà ou roumains je
côtoie beaucoup de monde des gens qui
travaillent des retraités les retraités
ils ont faim tous les jours j'ai
quelqu'un qui qui dit mais où on va on a
travaillé toute notre vie voilà on a
travaillé on a acheté une maison
maintenant on va plus pouvoir subvenir à
tout ce à quoi ils essayent de gratter
sur les trois ans qu'il reste trois
quatre ans avant de khalis paraissent
tout simplement faudrait qu il
qui disent le pourquoi mais des
arguments parce que là je sais pas
pourquoi le pourquoi de cette mesure
nous sommes allés le chercher auprès de
la municipalité qui justifie son double
choix douloureux
la taxe foncière est elle aussi en
augmentation un choix déjà expliquées
aux habitants en avril dernier à parler
de l'augmentation de 30% objectivement
canton l'annoncent comme ça c'est
choquant après c'est 30% de quoi c'est
toujours le voir il faut voir que sur
grand charmont d'à peu près 43 % de
logements sociaux qu'on a des bases
locatives qui ont été évalués en 1970
qui sont réévaluées dans les gaules
finir un petit mot tous les ans les
taxes n'avait pas connu de hausse depuis
22 ans à grand-charmont on relativise
donc car le taux d'imposition même en
augmentation à 15 26 % restent bien
en-deça de nombreux autres communes
ici on se défend d'avoir voulu profiter
de l'aubaine c'est vraiment parce que on
était arrivé à un niveau de 2 de baisse
de dotation qui ne nous permettaient pas
d'assurer l'avenir
en france la commune et au 47e rang des
plus pauvres dans celles comptant entre
5000 et 10000 habitants
[Musique]
beaucoup de choses sont dites 1 dans ce
sujet déjà on va revenir sur ce que dit
l'adapt dans la boulangerie elle dit
c'est la faute au gouvernement
jean claude grenier vous réagissez comme
ans quand vous entendez ça je pense que
le candide prison mâcon n'a pas tenu sa
promesse
il a tenu sa promesse le président
macron dit qu'il ya 30 % d'abattement
cette année il 65% de l'année prochaine
la suppression de la taxe d'habitation
dans trois ans il tient sa promesse
ce n'est les gens font l'amalgamé n'a
pas les moyens de la faire appliquer sur
le territoire et c'est vous les maires
et les présidents comme quand même si
des études ne fiscalité locale alahmad
des élus locaux
donc de toute façon aujourd'hui
l'engagement du président de la
république et de suppression de la taxe
d'habitation en trois ans avec un
dégrèvement
c'est un dégrèvement et compense les
collectivités locales à l'euro près
c'est son engagement cet adhérent est ce
que vous en tant que responsables
d'exécutifs vous ne resterez pas de la
part des contribuables
c'est l'état qui va nous le donner
exactement théoriquement et au 31
décembre 2010 est celle des chiffres qui
sont arrêtés voilà ajouté augmentation 2
2018 ne seront pas compensés par l'état
et ça c'est un nom c'est là justement
alors monsieur gagnon donc il ya un
contribuable qui dit en fait ils
augmentent pour que dans trois ans quand
la taxe sera supprimé l'état de nous
plus mais ça marche pas comme ça
non ça marche pas forcément comme ça
même si bien évidemment que c'est des
bases 2017 qui sont par exemple
2017 qui compte mais au delà de ça le
vrai problème est la vraie question
c'est comment on finance les
collectivités et dans trois ans ou
pendant trois ans aujourd'hui on doit
faire face à des baisses de dotations
qui ont commencé sur le gouvernement du
présent aux landes qui se sont accumulés
et que toute cette paix ses pertes
dotation ces dernières années conduit
aujourd'hui les collectivités dans des
circonstances compliquées compliqué on
va en parler alors vous christophe
lejeune comme je leur ai dit vous êtes
député de la république en marche et
buvait du petit lait quand vous entendez
gens que l'on craignait qu'il dit en
fait et my own maquereau a bien tenu sa
promesse
vous dites même que pour certains ça a
baissé pour beaucoup ça a baissé
moi je dis effectivement c'est une
promesse de campagne c'était une
promesse qui a été appliquée lors de la
loi de finances il ya un an et dont ça
se compte concrétise dans le budget des
ménages
aujourd'hui c'était très bien redis
c'est une promesse qui est nu et au
niveau des dotations j'entends ce que
dit mon collègue le maire de dole
effectivement elles ont baissé
les dotations globales pour les communes
versée par l'état ont baissé pendant de
nombreuses années et depuis 2018 avec ce
qui était proposé et mis en place par le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe avec
emmanuel macron nous avons gelé les
baisses de dotations
globalement au niveau national il n'y a
plus de baisses de dotations dans l'est
alors on va rester encore deux secondes
sur les contribuables ce que vous m'avez
dit c'est que pour un couple avec deux
enfants
s'ils gagnent moins de 5100 euros par
mois théoriquement il doit voir sa taxe
d'habitation
bc oui alors ça c'était ça c'est pas le
cas les gens qui sont devant leur
télévision peut vous appeler au 8 août a
fait c'est exactement les bases puisque
toute façon il faut arrêter une somme
pour qu'il y ait un dégrèvement et le
dégrèvement sur un couple avec deux
enfants du moment où ce couple ne
dépasse pas 5000 100 euros de revenus
mensuels
c'est quand même une somme rondelette eh
bien oui c'est plus de 4 fois le smic 1°
déjà pas mal avec bien d'accord donc ce
couple se verra effectivement des gréves
et de 30% de sa taxe d'habitation par
rapport à la taxe d'habitation de 2017
alors avant de parler d'aidé et des
recettes dans le détail
est-ce que c'est pas plus simple
monsieur grenier de faire déjà des
économies
c'est la première des choses mais je
crois que les économies beaucoup de
collectivités toutes plus elles sont
prêtes et collectivités plus elles
gèrent bien leur budget est toutes les
économies aujourd'hui je crois qu'on
arrivait au fond j'ai collé tout en
lever les étals à un moment donné on
adore on peut aller beaucoup plus loin
le problème majeur qu'on a c'est que non
seulement on a fait des économies mais
le gouvernement parce que là il faut
aussi le dire une blouse donne de plus
en plus de missions et de tâches qu'il
faisait de lui avant et maintenant
qu'ils mais je n'ai plus à me donner des
priorités tout simplement le droit du
sol
jusqu'il ya deux ans en arrière c'est
l'état castries y est les permis de
construire
castries et les demandes de travaux
aujourd'hui c'est les collectivités donc
communauté de communes qui font la
section du droit du sol la collectivité
refacture aux communes
l'instruction du droit du sol pour une
commune comme l'hôpital du grosbois ce à
peu près 6000 euros par an
c'est à 200 habitants à l'hôpital du
grosbois 180 habitants il ya deux ans en
arrière
ces 6000 euros ce service d'une valeur
de 6000 euros
c'est l'état qui nous le faisait
gratuitement
aujourd'hui c'est la commune qui paye la
gestion du parc informatique était
assumée par le conseil départemental
gratuitement aujourd'hui la commune
noter que la commune puisse arriver ça
fait 6000 par 6000 par là on va demander
à monsieur gagnon vous concrètement vous
avez moins d'argent
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il ya des
projets auxquels vous avez dû renoncer
alors renoncé non les étaler dans le
temps oui c'est à dire que on va moins
vite qu'avant pour faire des projets
parce qu'on est obligé d'étaler les
dépenses d'investissement sur plusieurs
années et en termes d'économies ça a été
dit on en a déjà fait beaucoup depuis la
baisse des dotations donc cbs qui est on
ne peut pas aller plus loin si mais est
ce que vous n'avez pas vu sur des
services à la population
est ce que vous n'avez pas eu pendant
des années j'allais dire un espèce d'âge
d'or et qu'il fallait quand même un peu
être raisonnable alors après
ça a traversé les mandats des uns des
autres mais je veux dire je crois
vraiment que si aujourd'hui on même ces
dernières années on peut constituer on
peut constater un certain nombre d'abus
je crois que c'était dans des
collectivités plus importante que les
communes
je veux pas dire mais les régions on
sait depuis longtemps que il ya eu
beaucoup dans bausch beaucoup de
recrutements programmés ce qu'on a vu là
puisque vous parlez en laisant mouche
mais on a vu que tous les présidents de
la république disait qu'il y avait moins
de fonctionnaires d'état
on a vu toutes vos structures que ce
soit les communes et surtout les
intercommunalités
vous avez embauché à tour de bras quand
à mains nues à dole on a baissé avec
l'agglomération de 30 équivalents temps
plein le père sur la ville la ville et
l'agglomération et vous monsieur
greenland de moi mais en fusion de
communautés commune qu'on vient de
réaliser
nous sommes aujourd'hui en moins trois
équivalents temps plein mais bien sûr
qu'on a embauché comme vous avez des
services supplémentaires à assumer
on va prendre l'eau et l'assainissement
dans quelques années il va bien falloir
augmenter nos effectifs pour assumer ces
services-là faut que par les effectifs
mais faut voir les compétences qu'on est
ensemble et moi je voudrais qu'on met en
parallèle les compétences avec les
effectifs
alors si vous prenez les chiffres bruts
évidemment qu'on monte en effectif mais
on monte en compétences ont fait on
assume de nouvelles compétences que
l'état n'assume plus est évidemment ça
baisse des effectifs de l'état ça montre
les effectifs des collectivités locales
alors vous parlais tout à l'heure
monsieur le jeune de la dotation globale
de fonctionnement c'est l'une des
recettes des communes et les communes on
prend pas 36 solutions
c'est où les impôts on en a parlé où
l'on prend et certains certaines
communes et interco sont quand même très
très endetté et puis les dotations de
l'état
un chiffre pour la dotation globale de
fonctionnement
47% des communes sont perdantes 53% sont
gagnantes ont honte parce qu'il ya tout
un système de péréquation etc
c'est assez compliqué on va pas rentrer
là dedans mais on n'entend plus les
perdantes que des gagnantes
il n'y a pas un problème de
communication de chez vous alors la
communication vous savez les chiffres
pour les
les expliquer à nos concitoyens c'est
toujours très compliqué je pense que
l'exemple d'une personne qui va
découvrir que finalement il ya des
perdants qui a des gagnants parce que la
dotation globale de fonctionnement
elle a baissé un endroit mais qu'elle a
augmenté à un autre et puis que la
péréquation mais il n'a capable de
péréquation horizontale y en a qui
parlent de c'est à dire au niveau de
tous les départements par exemple ou de
péréquation verticale c'est toutes les
communes d'une même strate
finalement tout le monde on arrive à
mélanger les éléments en réalité je
crois que ce qui est important de dire
c'est que depuis 40 ans le budget de
l'état a été systématiquement en déficit
à ce que les communes n'ont pas le droit
de faire elles n'ont pas le droit de
présenter un budget en eficien d'accord
et l'état leur impose sa et qui
s'imposent l'a lui-même mené bien
d'accord et ça c'est une réalité
j'ai été élu j'ai été maire je suis
toujours conseil municipal je sais le
côté vertueux des collectivités locales
1 où les élus savent remonter les
manches
au propre et au figuré ça c'est une
réalité s'il faut pas l'oublier faut
leur rendre hommage
par contre il ya aussi un discours de
vérité qu'on doit avoir vis-à-vis de nos
concitoyens quand on a un mandat
national c'est de dire que au rythme où
vont les déficits
au rythme auquel se creusent les
déficits ça devient intenable donc
l'effort il doit être partagée le
problème c'est que quand vous avez une
vision globale et bien l'effort rien
aquellos le sentiment de le partager
plus que d'autres nice est souvent vrai
mais ce n'est pas toujours vrai alors
emmanuel macron le président de la
république s'est exprimé cette semaine
après le remaniement ministériel il a eu
un petit mot pour vous les maires vous
les aidez le coup puisque vous êtes
toujours conseiller municipal à bout
d'os coup il a dit il faut que le pays
garde la maîtrise de son destin
et pour ça ils comptent vraiment sur
vous les élus locaux on écoute
emmanuel macron et cela exige de
s'appuyer sur toutes les forces du
progrès et de la réforme les
associations les élus locaux dans tous
nos territoires et en particulier nos
mères qui sont
les premiers porteurs de la république
du quotidien nous avons besoin en ces
temps troublés de toutes les énergies de
la nation et de toutes les bonnes
volontés jeu coûte grenier quand vous
avez autour du déjà ça vous fait sourire
ce passage à les dire de calinothérapie
si je peux me permettre vous avez réagi
comment pas disons que j'ai trouvé la
cohésion de la république bien triste je
pense pas qu'il était vraiment convaincu
par ce qu'ils nous disaient quand on est
chef d'equipe qu'on est premier de
cordée il faudra voir un peu plus
enthousiasme quoi les élus ils sont là
sur le terrain tous les jours ils sont
prêts aujourd'hui à ta à s'impliquer
il faut penser à tous ces bénévoles les
élus sont par définition bénévoles enfin
vous avez quand même des indemnités bien
sûr le maire d habiliter quelques
adjoints mais dans un conseil municipal
chez nous on est 15
les quinze travail et les cas c'est du
bénévolat et d'indemnités que vous
touchez si on rapporte ça au travail et
alors vous devez pas gagné grand chose
de leur puis surtout ce qu'on dépense
c'est vrai j'ai fait les comptes à la
maison à défaut elles des liens manque
plus à la fin du mois qu'est ce que tu
as ramené pour tes portes et indemnités
et pour le service que tu rends à la
collectivité mais ça c'est pas voir vous
fait pas pour l'argent
jean baptiste gagne ou quand vous avez
entendu au président de la république
vous avez réagi comment vous souriez où
vous êtes plus en colère ou ses petits
disons que on attend de voir un peu plus
encore le congrès des maires dans
quelques semaines
je crois que les élus locaux ils
attendent une clarification sur le
financement des collectivités
parce que il faut que ça soit davantage
et sans beaucoup d'inquiétude 1 dans vos
rangs beaucoup d inquiétude parce qu'il
ya ces transferts de compétences qui
sont qu'ils ne sont pas compensés à la
hauteur de 2 des dépenses que ça inclut
pour la collectivité
et puis il faut absolument que le
gouvernement et même la cre on refasse
confiance aux élus locaux
on n'a pas assez de message clair on
attend on a l'impression que on a sonné
vers une recentralisation à paris de
davantage d'aidé pouvoir il faut
davantage leur faire confiance je crois
que il ya un nouveau mini jacqueline
gourault il ya un nouveau gouvernement
et le congrès des maires qui arrive
c'est le moment ou jamais que l'état
renouent avec les collectivités
et je crois que sur cette histoire de la
taxe d'habitation le vrai problème c'est
que on n'a pas dit on à cacher
les choses c'est à dire qu'on a dit on
va baisser de 30% mais on n'a pas dit
attention sous réserve que les
collectivités locales n'augmentent pas
leurs impôts c'est pour ça qu'il ya de
la déception pour une petite partie de
la population entre nous là on est juste
entre nous emmanuel macron n'a jamais eu
de mandat local
c'est un manque d'écouté moi je ça
serait quand même très réducteur de dire
que pour comprendre il faut avoir fait
un mandat local et que pour être entendu
il faut avoir un mandat national
je crois qu'on peut pas réduire ce
schéma ces discussions à un simple
mandat local
je crois que la réalité c'est la
conviction celle enthousiasme vous avez
des présidents d'association qui sont
calmes et j'ai l'impression que des fois
il comprend pas ce qui se passe sur le
terrain
rassurez vous on est là pour lui dire
des écoutes et il est cool alors il vous
a peut-être pas beaucoup écouté vous les
élus de haute saône puisque cette
semaine a été annoncé la suppression de
la fameuse prison de lure
ça c'est un coup de poignard dans le dos
pour vous alors écoutons vous au sens
large et pas que pour christophe lejeune
c'est une grande déception pour les élus
qui ont travaillé sur ce dossier
tous les élus qui ont travaillé sur ce
dossier pour les associations qui ont
soutenu pour deux habitants y avait une
unanimité simplement puisque vous m'en
parler depuis 9h peut pas vous recevoir
aujourd'hui sans vous en parler et oui
en 2010 michèle alliot marie qui était
garde des sceaux avait un envoi par
faire tout l'historique de la présente
mesure non mais c'est cette école le
serpent de mer et je dirais que depuis
huit ans on parle de la fermeture de
cette prison est qu'en février 2010 est
en février de l'année dernière il ya 18
mois juste avant les élections
présidentielle et législatives aux as
qui est garde des sceaux sort la carte
des prisons des maisons d'arrêt qui vont
être réhabilités est la prison de lure
n'est pas sur cette carte
oui mais la défense c'est pas nous c'est
l'autre alors moi c'est un peu facile
hausse mais je dirais ça vous dit que
vous êtes déçu je vous vous sentez
abandonner dès fois par paris ah ben oui
mais le problème c'est qu'il eut
tellement de promesses de fait aux
quatre coins de france et qu'aujourd'hui
on est comptable c'est comme notre dame
des landes
ça fait cinquante ans que ça dure il ya
bien fallu le solde est un moment ou un
autre personne n'a voulu s'y atteler on
a pris une décision et là il ya un
moment il faut être le
il faut solder les promesses électorales
du passé alors on a parlé de jacqueline
gourault qui est la nouvelle ministre de
la cohésion des territoires elle hérite
d'un énorme ministère imaginons que vous
avez jacqueline gourault en face de vous
vous lui dites quoi on aurait beaucoup
de choses à se dire
je pense qu'on a on a la jambe et elle
était l'une dans une petite commune de
communes et aujourd'hui elle a vraiment
travaillé dans les mandats dans ses
mandats précédents dans sa
représentation mystères d'intérieur
précédent on l'a vu dans technique mais
pragmatique et aujourd'hui on a besoin
d'avoir ce type de mine east d'ailleurs
dès hier avoir à cirque et ce aux côtés
d'emmanuel macron personnellement je lui
ai écrit hier matin ah voilà pour une un
problème technique comptable qu'on
n'arrive pas à régler sur le plan local
depuis quelques années donc j'attends
maintenant que son pragmatisme soient
mises en oeuvre et j'espère la recevoir
au moins être reçu par son cabinet dans
les prochaines semaines pour aider les
problèmes qui nous perturbent à qui vous
envoyer la cuisse gauche alors et
monsieur gagnon imaginons vous avez
jacquiau gourou entrant en face de vous
vous lui dites quoi alors j'ai j'ai eu
la possibilité parce que je vais reçu
dans mon bureau à la mairie de dole il
ya trois quatre mois pour discuter avec
elle quand lorsqu'elle était en visite
dans le département
c'est quelqu'un qui écoute ça c'est
certain c'est quelqu'un qui écoute c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît les collectivités
maintenant tout va dépendre du 1er du
présent de la république sur l'attitude
qu'ils veulent avoir par rapport aux
collectivités je crois que c'est un bon
choix pour en termes de relations entre
les collectivités et le gouvernement
mais il faut qu'elles puissent y élevait
à impulser quelque chose de nouveau et
renouer le dialogue avec les élus locaux
il faut qu'on ait carrément renouer le
dialogue parce qu'il est intense mais il
me manque
il manque d'impulsion dans ce dialogue
de confiance et encore une fois on a le
sentiment que il ya moins de proximité
avec les élus locaux qu'il y en avait
auparavant et on ne peut pas tout
centraliser à paris il faut absolument
faire vivre les collectivités et on est
dans une société qui devient très
compliqué il ya une défiance envers
l'état il
les élus locaux ou encore un dernier
rempart pour istres et ils entendent ça
ils comprennent ça ils comprennent vos
inquiétudes ou pas est ce que oui parce
que dans une ambiance qui est difficile
et c'est tellement facile à mais en tant
que contribuable on veut toujours payer
moins et en tant qu'administrés on en
veut toujours plus sur la question de
l'accès à certains cas
dès qu'un effort est demandé c'est
forcément compliqué maintenant il faut
faire beaucoup de pédagogie a expliqué
christophe lejeune jacqueline gourault
donc est elle a été maire de la chaussée
saint victor victor de 4500 habitants ça
ça vous rassure quelqu'un comme elle aux
côtés d' emmanuel macron est évidemment
et puis je crois que avant de parler de
chacun gourou permettez moi de parler
aussi du premier ministre edouard
philippe
on a quand même un premier ministre qui
a été maire du havre d'une grande ville
qui a été député donc qu'ils allaient
les deux mandats on à jacqueline
gourault qui a été maire d'une petite
commune 4500 sera bien temps qui a été
sénatrice donc vraiment on a un tandem
qui est extraordinaire si les
discussions sont nécessaires et elles
sont nécessaires avec la réponse est là
la ministère la cohésion des territoires
avec le dialogue avec les élus locaux
je pense qu'aujourd'hui on est
clairement entendu on doit aller vers
une discussion un retour de la confiance
si la confiance a été entamée
effectivement il ya toujours des
inquiétudes mais la confiance elle est
quand même là puisqu'on travaille
ensemble on ce qu'on sait qui est
responsable et on sait qui est
irresponsable et aujourd'hui c'est pas
moi qui vais parler de d2 les
responsabilités des élus
les élus sont attachés à leur mandat à
leurs convictions ils portent des
valeurs et on doit être avec eux et on
est avec eux clairement et bien voilà
c'est un bon mot pour terminer cette
émission avait quand même une précision
d'ici trois ans plus personne ne payera
de taxe d'habitation
ça c'est une promesse d' emmanuel macron
il reste plus que 20 secondes donc je
vous remercie
messieurs d'avoir participé à cette
émission on a bien sûr parlé des bases
qui date de 1977 et des as mais il
faudrait faire une autre émission
voilà merci beaucoup pour votre
attention et bon dimanche après midi à
tous à revoir
[Musique]